marica louise elin à shell et le rat
soumaya ou zone à mahina nelio
what did à haousa
vodafone valentine naïma richmond darna
layana oui
je ne sais pas mais aussi madame est ce
que je peux l'accompagner
ah oui
[Musique]
l'émouvant attends je vais rester
non ça serait toujours à ses listes dans
roue tourne en grèce autre affaire
[Musique]
on retourne tous chez nous et on cherche
les partout dans tous les endroits où il
peut se cacher moi j'habite à bord
quelquefois je vois lui il va voir sa
grand mère
[Musique]
moi je vais aller autant de la rue de
saint louis
après j'ai donc appelé aussi oui si tu
viens avec moi
oui enfin c'est très sportif c'est très
bien je peux apercevoir une petite
cabane peut-être que louis s'est cachée
du dans quelques grands comptes n va
très bien c'est la réserve naturelle qui
est passé de ce trajet dans leur
législation l'avant voyez bien partout
[Musique]
qui veut se terminera moi j'ai peur
droit on peut y aller ensemble
[Musique]
je m'amuse et là au lieu de chercher
les censeurs on va plus de fierté tout
[Musique]
on
sabrine et partir
croix qui s'est fait oublier
et
[Musique]
avec la note qu'il a eu un match qu'il a
peur de se faire engueuler
[Musique]
c'est pas les raisons qui mentent
si vous étiez prêt à faire une bêtise
vous iriez ou
[Musique]
je sais au débarcadère
on allègera oui
[Musique]
ce que monique catta
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]